hello I'm Tyler Lansdowne community
specialist of NetherRealm Studios and we
have some exciting news for you about
the future of mortal kombat x and
specifically online play we've listened
to you on facebook and twitter and now
it's time to announce starting on
january nineteen we will begin signups
for a close public beta for the new and
improved online play with the online
beta release of mortal kombat x we are
attempting to move away from the dynamic
input latency model towards a model that
preserves the feel of an offline game
more accurately while playing online and
maintains a consistent input response
the model we are moving towards a
similar and function to the ggpo model
and could be described as a rollback
simulate forward model this means that
our engine will no longer have to wait
for both players to agree on input
before drawing its results to the screen
this creates a smoother gameplay
experience and diminishes the feeling of
lag in online play starting Tuesday
anyone who has accrued one hour of
online play time in mortal kombat x can
sign up for the beta ad beta moral
Kombat calm now keep in mind not
everyone can be invited to participate
but as the beta moves forward we will
continue to add players to the pool only
four characters will be playable at the
beginning of the beta those characters
are scorpion sub-zero Jackie Briggs and
Johnny Cage we plan on adding more
characters throughout the beta so
hopefully you'll be able to play your
favorite combatant mortal
we are excited to bring a whole new
online experience in Mortal Kombat X and
make sure you follow at nether realm on
Twitter for more information about the
beta maintenance alerts and maybe some
beta codes we will need your feedback at
the end of each play session a short
questionnaire will pop up on the screen
simply answer the questions providing
honest and objective feedback after each
match will provide nether own studios
with very valuable information we also
encourage you to provide feedback on the
MKX forums and stream your game play
this is your opportunity to help us
collect data and continue to refine our
online experience Thanks we'll see you
online